Sakyong we are here for living out loud
awkward dad but today we have a very
special episode that you could tell the
format's a little difference because
we're doing something different I have a
video guide now because you know I'm
ballin like that
so anyways today's a very special
episode of living out loud I've actually
been to this event before it's actually
a creative space called a little meets
la now for those of you guys out there
who don't know what little meets la is
little Mesa la is a platform for a lot
of up-and-coming chefs to go ahead and
test their foods on a Clive face that
they don't normally have so it's really
a platform for them to kind of get a
name for themselves and build up the
menu build up their food and I will
actually talk about it more when we may
be the creative little meats Robin and
yeah we're here to have some fun so are
you excited oh and today's gonna be a
very special episode you know why right
because Matt UN is the chef today so
Matt I met him last time and today is
actually going to be his very last day
cooking for little means so it's very
special he told us a very heartwarming
story last time which is why I wanted to
shoot this on it and prepare to be moved
to tears if not you have no soul and
nobody loves you
kiss me in front of camera so you can
show people you love me okay
the mentality here is is omakase because
if never hearda term is when you go eat
at a fine-dining sushi restaurant
omakase essentially means you are the
expert chef I want you to give me your
best present to me the best you're the
expert I'm the consumer impress me with
that Sunday suppers as much as you guys
get to reap the benefits of the chefs
and the cooks who are making food for
you guys but at the end of the day it's
really about the chef and it's really
about the cook for the particular
evening and essentially in this type of
situation Matt is obviously cooking and
this is one of his passions of what he
does all we do is is we fill up the
seats we let people shine and do what
they want to do
quickly since I was like a little kid
eight years old you know learning him
like in my grandma's kitchen yeah taught
me you know how to cut how to code the
night tell me how to you know foil
vegetables you know I feel the time I
boil water you know and so I learned
everything from her and growing up as an
Asian kid you know your parents they
have this like Creed destined end goal
for you you know I was like maybe they
want you to go to college and be
successful and and that's great and they
want you to be a doctor you know a
lawyer accountant but anything but
coming a chef you're like on their list
you know and so I did that was a good
Asian kid listen to the mom and dad went
to college did the whole thing got out
of school with the business degree and
you know working working the business
world and it was great but got to the
point where I was like man I can't do
this anymore you know it's like I've
always had this like this thirst you
know for being a cook and always wanted
to be in the kitchen and my grandma got
really sick I left my job and went home
and just trying to spend more time with
there and I remember her you know before
she passed away she she sat me down we
talked and and now she solved the look
in my eyes like I wasn't happy like
doing what I was doing she and she knew
how much I wanted to be a cook and she
told me you know do what you love you
know it doesn't matter what it is but do
what you love and life would be much
more enjoyable
and so that wasn't that was a turning
point I was blowing I was like you know
what I'm gonna cook I'm gonna cook the
rest of my life it's what I want to do
is matter all my parents think and I
remember starting off like in the
industry as a dishwasher making eight
bucks an hour's eight bucks an hour you
know before that I had a career making
over $100,000 a year
and telling your parents you know who
want you to be all this love have been
the crazy lover station I can tell you
they were at this point what do you want
to be I want to cook also you want to go
on okay yeah go mommy earlier so I could
kill you but it alone piece of [ __ ] yeah
so I mean but it's been a journey you
know I went from being a dishwasher and
now you know sous chef at a great
restaurant here in LA and it's an
amazing journey but doesn't stop people
always talk about passion yeah passion
please do and do what you love and do
the things we're passionate about but a
lot of people don't stand is also having
a dry and having a desire to be
successful you know you can't passions
not going to drive you every single day
and with some days you wake up and
sometimes yeah I don't want to go in the
kitchen and don't have creative ideas
but I have this strong desire to be a
really great show and that's what keeps
me going and the passion comes back when
I keep pushing and keep driving and no
matter how broke I am some days as a
cook you know I keep pushing forward
because knowing the fact that at the end
of the day I'm gonna be better and the
next day will be better and the next
interview better and finally at some
point I'll be
my own restaurant so that's dope man but
that's so true though I think like even
when I was doing a stand-up comedy it's
funny because like I am in a lot of
youtubers who they're so used to hearing
the word yes you know on YouTube it's a
space where honestly you put out a plug
content the worst thing that you get is
a couple of kids making funny when they
tear down your video that's like the
most thing is like that's funny because
like when I was a standard comedian when
I first started out to 16 year old kids
going on stage and when you're trying to
stand up as a 16 Oh kid to adults people
don't have a [ __ ] about you first stage
for show every day like I walked up
people do move you know but they don't
people don't see the hardship that it
takes to get to where you're at right
now you know and and you know I'll be it
like there are people on YouTube who
don't have to go through that experience
because the platforms change you know
they can go on there do whatever they
want and they'll be successful but it's
funny because some of these youtubers
I've talked to they audition for a movie
roles and they go in and they don't know
you suck and they step outside of my
other something I know that's the
experience right there's like building
blocks for you to get where you want you
know and that whole I think that's the
trials and tribulations that kind of
build you to be something stronger or
you have to hear the word know sometimes
you gotta fail you know and I think so
many people are afraid of that that's
why when we started this go-for-broke
motto was just failure is an option it
can happen
yeah you know it's so post to happen you
know but at the end of the day if you
keep on betting small chips you only get
small returns of course you know so then
your story is great - appreciate it
I love you anyway
amen so tonight's experience was a it
was interesting dude like that's
basically what the little meets is about
I mean it's kind of one of my for me
it's a it's a place that I really like
to come I mean more than just the food
it's like it's about the experience that
you get and meeting these people I mean
these people are are unique individuals
you know you know when it comes to a
food I think a lot of the times I
mentioned it before people forget how
much of an art it is you know and for
format he really kind of had to give up
what he was doing which was his safety
net in order to pursue what he wanted to
do which was his passion and like he
even said before like sometimes your
passions when you wake up at the end of
the day and you don't want to do it it's
your drive that's going to get you
through it you know a lot of you out
there are passionate about what you're
doing and you know you use well you say
it and then when things get tough you're
like I don't think it's made for me well
that's how life is supposed to be tough
and little meets it's all about that
like I've met certain individuals here
that in all honesty they inspire me Matt
told me he was a huge fan of my youtube
channel and it was very inspiring to
watch my stuff I watch him and cook in
the kitchen and it inspires me back I
mean that's a blessing in themselves so
you know I love little meets LA if you
guys ever have an opportunity to be a
part of little meets you can contact
them to be a guest at one of those
dinners it's very exclusive but we're
trying to make it a little bit bigger so
let's let's do what we can
I'll see y'all next episode tell them
you love me on camera right now hey say
it say
see she's hugging me she's hugging my
throat go ahead thank you